le matthieu suc bonjour veaux publié aux
éditions du moment renault nid d'espions
consacré cette affaire de vrais ou de
faux espionnage plutôt qui a qu'à qui a
fait la une des journaux alors tout a
commencé le 3 janvier pour le public en
tout cas le 3 janvier 2011 avec
l'audition de trois cadres de renault
qui sont soupçonnés d'espionnage
tout à fait et dans la foulée une
dépêche afp va annoncer la faire et que
renault se sépare de trois hauts
dirigeants ont peu ça ne s'est pas
n'importe qui on n'est pas voilà qui
sont soupçonnés d'avoir livré des
secrets industriels
on évoque la chine que la chine est en
plus sur un sujet ô combien sensible
c'est celui du véhicule électrique qui
est le grand paris de carlos ghosn le
pdg de renault qui dit que le véhicule
et rick va être la voiture du futur et
qui déploie des moyens considérables au
regard de l'entreprise là tu donc c'est
quand même très très rare qu'une affaire
d'espionnage et sorte de de la sorte et
donc les médias sont en parlons
médiatisé que tout le monde sur les
politiques les membres du gouvernement
vont à qui mieux mieux dans les médias
pour dire que c'est une affaire grave et
les trois personnes mises en cause vont
à leur tour aller dans les médias pour
crier leur innocence à l'armée parce que
il faudra compter la coc dire qu'ils
sont convoqués par des cadres de renault
et on leur dit on sait ce que vous
faites
on est au courant donc soit vous
démissionnez et on aimerait ça s'arrête
là soit sinon ça va aller très mal bons
essais de matisse mais de quoi de quoi
vous nous parler ben oui ça c'est en
plus d'autant plus violent c'est qu'ils
sont convoqués pour des motifs futiles
le jour 2 le retour des vacances c'est
bonjour comme on va dire mention bien
passé toi tu étais ou au ski machin à et
au fait un pourri et tu tiens on dire
je caricature mais à peine est il tombé
et tombe des nues ils comprennent pas du
tout et donc ils vont avoir les 3
et puis leur nom après ça et on va avoir
une ligne de défense très dur et très
véhémente en disant on est innocent et
voilà et alors on leur reproche parce
que il faudra compter comme donc d'avoir
espionné probablement pour la chine
d'avoir des comptes à l'étranger au
luxembourg où on se lance sans le
découvre au fur et à mesure deux des
révélations dans la presse
effectivement il aurait rapidement on
voit qu'en fait renault parle
d'espionnage industriel manque s'est pas
véritablement les secrets qu'ils
auraient doléances clé dans l'odyssée
sur le véhicule électrique mais on ne
sait pas quoi et que en fait les seules
preuves entre guillemets corps r honos
c'est que ces trois quatre possèdent des
comptes secrets cachés au liechtenstein
en suisse avec des sommes monstrueuses
qui sera versée par se construisent et
puis on s'aperçoit qu'elle serait pas si
monstrueuse que ça va également sa
dépose ça dépend des gens ça dépend des
comptes
il ya des choses ça parce qu'il ya des
cadres de renault qui sont alertés de
cette affaire qui regarde l'heure des
les côtés et qui se disent mais attendez
pour et iliad nous sommes je parle 45000
euros etc
quelqu'un va pas mettre sa carrière en
danger pour une somme qui est pas une
somme égale et les sommes grossiste dont
certains voient là on a toute une chaîne
un schéma assez complexe avec plein de
sociétés-écrans master et qui arrive sur
la chine alors il faut dire pardon hein
il ya donc ces trois cadres qui sont
accusés et puis il ya alors il ya d'où
ça vient ces accusations et un service
de sécurité interne à ce qui est normal
voilà
composé de ce qu'on appelle des
barbouzes les anciens des services de
renseignement saïk anciens voilà et
c'est eux qui ont mené l enquête alors
on découvre que renan à façon enquête
dans son coin
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas du tout
lily à un service français qui s'appelle
la des séries qui lui montre espionnage
et dans le rôle est justement de
défendre les intérêts de la france
contre des intrusions contre des des
espions les intérêts de la france c'est
à dire les services de l'état qui pourra
être espionnés mais bien sûr aussi les
entreprises françaises renault a
sciemment choisi de squeeze et sunshine
de faire català il faut dire qu'au début
il ya une lettre anonyme qui démarre
c'est tout à fait marrer de tout démarre
d'une lettre de dénonciation d'un
corbeau qui au jour d'aujourd'hui mais
n'a toujours pas été il aurait essayé et
donc qui met en cause nommément un cave
qui donne des éléments urbains d'autres
jeunes etc
mais on va trouver assez facilement
enfin il ya celui qui est nommé 1
et puis il ya ceux qui sont désignés
comme ça qu'on va trouver à la cpi et le
service de sécurité de renault à partir
de ça et de ce que leur demandait les
dirigeants va faire appel à un espèce de
gorge profonde informateur as well as ou
qu'ils appellent la source une espèce de
gorge profonde qui sera au courant de
tout et qui auraient des capacités
d'investigation extraordinaire il serait
il serait comment aller voir les voir
mais on compte de la porte qui à
n'importe où dans le monde
beaucoup de choses et augmentant dans
votre livre parce que ça alors c'est
vraiment un monde presque un roman
d'espionnage d'affectation d'être dans
la fiction or c'est la réalité
mais par exemple cette gorge profonde
cet informateur alors c'est un des ddd
type du service sécurité qui est en
rapport avec lui mais qui ne veut jamais
dû le déni son nom ni qui les donne
juste le protège il promet vis-à-vis de
ses supérieurs
voilà et est ce qui est d'autant plus
surprenant au regard du nom d'une aussi
grande entreprise s'est parlé on est
quand même de triel on n'est pas dans
une petite pme c'est que renault accepte
sans problème fait des fausses factures
pour rémunérer événements son indicateur
sans savoir qui s'est marié le sens des
phrases sonnent comme un bruit on est
sur trois sont ils auraient paye sans
regarder son contrôle qu'est la qualité
ça va grincer les dents des informations
et sans savoir qui c'est le fait est que
au fur à mesure de l'enquêté de police
denos enquête journalistique on va
découvrir que finalement les trois
cadres qui ont été licenciés qui ont été
vilipendés finalement leur compte qu'on
leur alloue n'existe que par alors
qu'ils sont attirants innocents des
trucs avec 110 02 d'allemagne en suisse
on ne va même pas voir jusqu'à la banque
enfin oui c'est il ya des choses mais
surréaliste enfin assez on est du côté
des pieds des pieds nickelés assez assez
régulièrement ces gens n'ont entre john
le carré ce que dit elle ça commence
comme james ellroy safely comme les
pieds nickelés et les pieds nickelés
c'est en effet les trois nés trois
responsables des services de sécurité
entre autres elle à dire légende renault
qui qu'ils font quand même des actes et
qui joue qui jouent aux agents secrets
aux jazz ont de même il ya l'avocat de
renault qui se rend en belgique pour
aller voir la source mystérieuse enfin
c'est pas le rôle d'un avocat afin suivi
l suivi qui prend peur on est on
pourrait dire qu'on est dans un mauvais
roman d'espionnage
malheureusement c'est vrai après en
interne de renault et c'était un des
buts de de mon enquête
c'était d'aller voir au delà de la
sphère elle même de remonter sur 10 ans
pour aider les revoilà il ya eu hier
chose c'est pas la première et ça fait
un peu boule de neige se terre qu'on a
une entreprise qui au fur et à mesure du
règne de principalement de carlos ghosn
parce que lui-même et paranoïaque et
obsédé par les anti enfin la lentille ce
d'être d'être espionnés c'est pas le
seul patron en prenant nourrit peut-être
et au fur et à mesure des petites
affaires eh ben on en sort des plus gros
risques et on s'aperçoit que les
trois-quarts enfin toutes les affaires
sont fausses et que depuis dix ans on
licencie des gens chez renault sur de
fausses accusations et sauf que quand on
vous lit sans si vous êtes tout seul et
que vous êtes un ingénieur mashup vous
dites je me prendre je ne prends de
renault sur le râble c'est compliqué on
trouve que je me retrouve dehors il va
franche payer un avocat perd contre le
docteur et et tout le monde baisse les
bras
généralement hélas cela montre agressif
on les a sauvées quoi alors je pense
qu'il ya aussi autre chose c'est que
c'est des gens qui sont un haut niveau
donc qui ont des moyens financiers ils
vont prendre de très bons avocats
et puis ils sont trois à tous elles
n'ont qu'à un moment
voilà vous sentez et effectivement c'est
médiatique donc à un moment ils sont dos
au mur ils sont obligés d'aller de
l'avant et ce qui va permettre de
découvrir qu'en fait tout ça est un
tissu de mensonges
on verra évidemment à votre livre parce
que y est absolument dans l'impression
qu'on est alors que les faits sont vrais
les conséquences de cette fureur carlos
ghosn a sauvé sa tête
oui il aurait pu être quand même menacé
quand même il va lui même à la
télévision au 20h accusé trois cadres de
chez lui
kid est obligé ensuite de réintégrer
certains sont d'ailleurs accepté cette
réintégration
les deux autres dont il va se sauver
le numéro 2 pélata patrick pélata lui
lui var a sauté vers un fusible ainsi
qu'un certain nombre de dirigeants
il va outre des gens qui ont participé à
l'enquêté au fiasco
les barbouzes évidemment les barbouzes
est bien évidemment mais aussi mais
aussi des claviers tous les hauts
dirigeants qui
on menait ou driver l'enquète de
services de sécurité qui est et qui sont
plantés parce que donc et moi c'est
aussi un des intérêts enfin l'une de mes
motivations sur ce livre c'était d'aller
voir la question de la gouvernance de
renault
comment ça sera et la question des
lettres est ce que les vrais
responsables ont payé votre sentiment
abba clairement carlos ghosn sauf sa
tête alors que il est largement
responsable
il a sa part de responsabilité du match
après c'est pas mon rôle
oui le grief que c'est à lui sauté ou
pas farceur je n'ai pas deux mais ce que
je raconte c'est que ou ce que je révèle
c'est que là où carlos ghosn avait dit
mais moi il ya eu des audits
on a considéré que j'étais responsable
en rien et tous les responsables ont
sauté oui bien sur l'eau dce ne le met
pas en cause on les pose aucune question
il ya une phrase que vous citez la
deuxième fois où il va la télévision
pour derrière pas eu d'exploit mal on
lui dit mais vous êtes responsable dit
nous sommes restés là il prend pas
l'avion s'est mis à me hisser son
sabilité la sphère pas un pli de la
ferme n'est pas terminé il y aura un
procès voilà que les notamment les gens
de services de sécurité ils sont accusés
de viol un qui est mis en examen l'heure
actuelle on va voir fait une escroquerie
parce que la ligne est très soucieuse de
son ca river on le soupçonne de l'avoir
fait ça pour garder l'argent qui est tel
que renault versés de manière illégale à
la source et puis barbotait l'argent et
il n'y avait aucune source il ya vos
carences pour l'instant présomption
d'innocence avant lui conteste l'oeuf
cette personne la comtesse on verra s'il
va jusqu'au procès ou s'il arrive à
établir son innocence
il ya tout un tas de délits connexes qui
ont été faits et il ya l'instruction qui
est encore en cours qui est pas prête de
se terminer
j'ai encore appris hier que il y avait
de nouveaux acteurs qui à l'aide
demandée de l'appart divers avocats
notamment suite aux révélations libre
donc ça va être dans un angle de
peut-être le fin mot de l'histoire on
l'aura dans un monde
o2 est en tout cas alors si on veut tout
savoir sur cette affaire est absolument
passionnant faut lire renault nid
d'espions c'est au co édition du bon mot
merci d'un coup médiatique